ما بين هدنه صامده واخرى كاجراحهم يستغيث
السودانيون من ويلات النزوح واللجوء
داخليا وضع انساني كارثي وحاجه ماسه
للخدمه الطارئه اما الطريق الى دول الجوار
فمحفوف بالمتاعب وكلاهما مشقه ومعاناه في
الوصول بسلام منظمه الهجره الدوليه اكدت
ان عدد النازحين في الداخل تضاعف خلال
اسبوع من 340 الفا الى اكثر من 700 الف
اما اجمالي الاحصاءات منذ بدء المعارك بلغ
قرابه ثلاثه ملايين وسبعمائه الف مشرد في
حين رصدت المنظمات الامميه 100 الف من
لاجئين خارج مع توقعات بوصولهم الى 800
الف وعن القتلى فتخطى عددهم حاجز
السبعمائه وخمسين شخصا ونحو 5000 جريح
وبينما تناكف اعمده الدخان المتصاعده خيار
النزوح
امنا في المدن البعيده عن بؤر الصراع اذ
يعاني اقليم دارفور وضعا انسانيا خانقا في
معسكرات نازحيه وكانت ابرز وجهه الهاربين
الداخليا واكثرها هدوءا مدينه واد مدني في
ولايه الجزيره ومنها ينتقلون شرقا وجنوبا
الى سنار وكسلا والقضارف والنيل الازرق
كما وجدوا في الولايه الشماليه حصنا امنا
من الاشتباكات اما مدينه كوستي بولايه
النيل الابيض فتعد ثاني اكثر المدن ايواء
للفرين من جحيم الحرب
ولايات ما كان اختيارها بالنسبه للمدنيين
عبثيا وانما تكاتف السودانيين في محنه
بلادهم كان دليلا على تعاونهم بمبادره
الاهالي على فتح بيوتهم لاستقبال النازحين
اسراء الصغير العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات